vous avez deux feuilles bonjour
Messieurs
mes chers collègues donc je vais
présider et remplacer
rémiintro ce matin donc messieurs merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
échanger sur la question importante de
l'eau avec les membres de la mission
d'information lancée en février à la
demande du groupe socialiste et qui
comprend des sénateurs de toutes les
sensibilités
notre audition du jour fait l'objet d'un
compte-rendu et d'une retransmission
nous devrions achever nos travaux fin
juin début juillet par un rapport qui
contiendra notre analyse de la politique
de l'eau menée dans notre pays et des
propositions pour l'améliorer tenant
compte de tous les avis que nous aurons
entendus
Météo France est un acteur essentiel
pour connaître les volumes de pluie ou
encore l'humidité des sols et observer
les transformations du climat renforcer
notre expertise est également
essentielle pour mieux gérer notre eau
de main affiner nos modèles
prédictif et ne pas être pris de cours
par la transformation de notre
environnement nous souhaitons donc vous
entendre et pouvoir échanger sur la base
du questionnaire que vous avez reçu
messieurs je passe maintenant la parole
à notre rapporteur Hervé Gier
merci madame la Présidente je remercie
également mes collègues d'être présent
je renouvelle les remerciements pour
votre disponibilité sur cette mission
d'information qui est un peu plus
Camille parcours maintenant
qui est quand même assez large donc nous
avons un nombre d'auditions assez
soutenu dans un contexte que vous
connaissez tous qui met en lumière un
certain nombre de problématiques et de
sujets et quelque part même si le
contexte est délicat nous sommes dans un
moment important sur le plan politique
justement pour essayer de mettre en
lumière un certain nombre d'enjeux
l'approche bien sûr prédictive et les
connaissances la consolidation des
connaissances est absolument essentielle
sur ce sujet à différents niveaux que ça
soit sur une meilleure connaissance de
la ressource une meilleure connaissance
des usages mais bien évidemment une
meilleure connaissance des aléas et donc
votre avis vos
prospectives sont absolument
essentielles dans ce cadre-là
je crois que vous avez prévu une
présentation qui va nous permettre de
rebondir sur un certain nombre de
questions que que l'on souhaite vous
poser quand on vous a transmis au
travers donc du questionnaire donc
Monsieur le Directeur général je vous en
prie si vous souhaitez quelques mots
luminaires bien sûr
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le sénateur bon bonjour
mesdames et messieurs donc effectivement
je me présente Alain directeur général
adjointe Météo France je suis accompagné
de Jean-Michel Soubirou directeur
adjoint scientifique de la Direction des
Services climatologiques de du climat et
des services climatologiques qui est
basé à Toulouse la direction générale de
Météo France est basée à Saint-Mandé ils
sont trop opérationnel se trouve à
Toulouse donc c'est vraiment avec
plaisir qu'on a répondu à votre à votre
demande d'audition
je pense qu'il est utile effectivement
de partager un petit peu toutes les
connaissances dans le domaine de l'eau
de la politique de l'eau et nous sommes
vraiment
[Musique]
partenaire pour que alimenter votre
rapport qui vous permettra de progresser
tous ensemble donc merci pour cette
initiative et donc effectivement nous
avons prévu une présentation une
présentation en deux temps je vais
rappeler rapidement les missions un
petit peu institutionnelles de de France
et particulièrement celle qui qui
concerne qui concerne tout ce qui est
pluviométrie hydrométrie et ensuite
on commencera à rentrer un petit peu
dans le détail sur l'état des lieux les
perspectives en matière liées au
changement climatique et ça c'est
Jean-Michel soubiro qui présentera cette
cette partie là nous avons également
préparé les les réponses aux
questionnaire que vous nous avez
envoyées alors nous voulons encore
envoyer maintenant nous serons
l'occasion de l'enrichir au cours de de
ces échanges et ensuite bien sûr nous
vous transmettons
nos réponses à ces questionnaire par par
envoi par transmission donc la la
présentation est également bien sûr à
votre disposition voilà donc
Météo France aujourd'hui très très
succinctement donc
les chiffres de 2022 en matière de ce
qu'on appelle recette mais 394 millions
d'euros qui
sont répartis de la manière suivante il
y a trois grands trois grandes
répartitions il y a une subvention
d'État vous voyez à hauteur de 44% en
jaune
il y a une partie qui est liée aux
redevance aéronautique donc quand vous
prenez quand vous prenez l'avion vous
payez une partie du billet ce contient
une taxe qui revient à Météo France au
travers de ce qu'on appelle les
redevances aéronautiques pour assurer la
sécurité des vols et il y a également
une activité commerciale à la météo
France donc des recettes propres donc à
hauteur de 9%
ensuite il y a
une somme non négligeable qui est
indiqué ici en orange le médecin 64
millions d'euros mais nous jouons un peu
la boîte aux lettres c'est à dire qu'on
a une subvention du Ministère de la
Recherche qui ensuite transmis à eux
médecins d'une organisation européenne
qui est chargée de
mettre en place de maintenir des
satellites météorologiques européens
et donc après vous avez différentes ce
qu'on appelle entre 9% ce sont des
subventions des subventions hautes que
la subvention d'État dans le cadre de
convention bien particulière par exemple
nous avons une convention avec la DGPR
pour qui nous finance à hauteur de 50%,
nous investissements radars par exemple
voilà donc les missions sont fixées par
un décret du division de 1993 il faut
savoir que Météo France était auparavant
une administration
centrale qui est devenue EPA
établissement public à caractère
administratif sous la tutelle du
ministère de la transition écologique et
la cohésion des territoires donc EPA en
juin 93 et modifier le 9 juin 2016 voilà
donc sous plafond d'emploi
en fin 2021 2595 ETP pour le schéma
d'emploi pour 2023 c'est 2558
il faut savoir que c'est un peu alors
attendez je vais vous expliquer ça
augmente par rapport à 2022 vous n'avez
pas le chiffre de 2022 de 2022 est
inférieur à 2558 et donc pour la
première fois depuis 10 ans pour la
première fois depuis 10 ans nous
effectifs à Météo France augmentent donc
de 58 et nous étions 3800 en il y a 10
ans donc il y a à peu près une baisse
régulière des effectifs de Météo France
de 3% par an depuis 10 ans vous êtes
dans une maison un certain nombre
d'entre nous vous défendent dans le
cadre
et c'est sans doute grâce à vous que
nous avons obtenu un relèvement de
schéma d'emploi il faut savoir pas
directement un lien direct avec avec
l'eau mais néanmoins il faut savoir que
parmi ces 58 et TP supplémentaires il y
en a 17 qui sont liés à au développement
de notre service pour en matière de feu
de forêt pour la prévention des feux
c'est à dire on va étendre ce qu'on
faisait dans le sud-est de la France on
va l'étendre au sud-ouest et à l'ouest
et donc ça va me permettre de couvrir 55
département forcément sur l'ensemble de
la France alors qu'on couvrait une
quinzaine de départements et et et et
donc
on a dit on peut le faire mais mais mais
mais avec nos effectifs on y arrivera
pas et donc finalement nous a entendu
vous nous avez entendu vous avez défendu
et donc on a pu avoir ces 17 et
supplémentaires pour les feux
donc le budget j'en ai parlé on a un
contrat d'objectif qui est signé avec
notre tutelle donc qui est sur 5 ans
2022 2026 donc là on a dans sa deuxième
année on a on avait un contrat
budgétaire
2018-2022 sauf que maintenant on n'a pas
de le budget ne souhaite pas renouveler
cette expérience donc nous avons un
contrat d'objectif et de performance
mais nous n'avons pas de contributeur
c'est-à-dire que peut-être un contrat
d'objectif de performance et de moyens
non mais voilà c'était avant il y avait
un com effectivement mais non c'est
devenu un coq et et alors il y avait un
peu le contrat d'objectifs et de moyens
au travers du contrat budgétaire en 2018
2022 il s'était un peu déc d'ailleurs et
mais mais mais voilà cela dit c'était
protecteur d'une certaine manière en
matière de subvention d'État mais en
revanche ça nous engageait en matière de
baisse d'effectif sur le contrat de
militaire 2018-2022 il y avait il y
avait l'inscription de - 95 et TP chaque
année donc et un chiffre qui est
important alors après bien sûr ça peut
prêter la caution mais on avait fait
faire des études par des sociétés
spécialisées externe
[Musique]
l'activité de Météo France un rapporte
permet de de
d'économiser d'avoir des bénéfices
sociaux économiques de l'ordre de 1,1 à
2,6 milliards d'euros donc voilà il faut
avoir ces France stratégiques qui
avaient fait cette étude en 2018 il faut
savoir qu'on avait également renouvelé
plus spécifiquement pour le remplacement
de notre supercalculateur de manière à
motiver le
l'investissement important de dans un
nouveau supercalculateur et là aussi on
regardait ce que ça apporter de de
mettre un euro pour se faire qualiteur
par rapport aux bénéfice
socio-économiques voilà donc c'est
important d'avoir
les rapports sans public et je pense que
c'est utile de montrer que que le
service de prévision météo mais aussi
les services climatologie permettent de
mieux anticiper et donc de faire des des
économies voilà on peut passer à la
diapos suivante merci d'ailleurs je vous
ai pas remercié de faire cette passage
de diapo merci beaucoup
alors très très rapidement la première
mission de Météo France est assurée la
sécurité météorologique justement et
donc le produit phare de Météo France
c'est la carte de vigilance au travers
de informer les autorités les citoyens
moyens de la carte de vigilance elle est
diffusée sur nos sites internet sur les
applications mobiles sur Twitter il faut
savoir que la carte de vigilance aussi
je fais un petit peu de pédagogie la
carte de vigilance elle est issue des
tempêtes de décembre 99
où on nous avait reproché que la chaîne
d'alerte n'était pas suffisamment
performante et donc la carte de
vigilance c'est quoi c'est informé en
même temps les autorités les services
chargés de la mise en place des secours
les médias et le grand public la
formation est voilà et cette carte de
vigilance elle s'est améliorée au fur et
à mesure donc de
ça fait maintenant plus de 20 ans elle a
une existence de plus de 20 ans on a
augmenté le nombre de paramètres
on a augmenté la tout récemment
l'échéance puisqu'à présent c'était des
cartes de vigilance qui portaient sur 24
heures maintenant nous avons deux cartes
de vigilance par jour une pour le jour J
et une pour le lendemain qui puissant
voilà et donc c'est diffusé au travers
des médias notamment également
avec les fameuses couleurs vert jaune
orange et rouge alors vous savez que
également pour cette saison pour cette
première saison estivale nous allons
mettre en place cette belle carte de
vigilance ça c'est ça s'en rapprochera
quand même une carte feu une carte des
la météo des forêts je sais pas si vous
avez il y a eu une communication presse
de notre ministère des tutelles
et et et
et voilà et ça va être mis en place à
partir de de
apporter également un soutien aux
différents services de l'État donc la
sécurité du trafic aérien j'en ai parlé
nous avons des redevances en retour
garantir la sécurité des routes avec les
services techniques nous avons beaucoup
de conventions notamment dans le cadre
d'un cadre commercial avec les DDT avec
les autoroutes
donc les conseils départementaux plutôt
et avec les autoroutes il conseille
départementaux palais des tétées
soutient la sécurité civile en
particulier pour la prévoration et la
lutte
j'ai fait un lapsus pas de souci voilà
cela dit nous avions des conventions
commerciales avec les drames aussi
soutient la sécurité civile en
particulier pour la prévention et la
lutte contre les feux de forêt et
végétation et puis un soutien également
important force armées
voilà et donc si on rentre plus précis
effectivement dans le dans le vif de du
sujet qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
notre appui au service de l'État dans le
domaine de l'eau compte trois volets
d'abord le suivi vous avez fait
référence tout à l'heure c'est le
travers d'un réseau de mesure il faut
savoir
quel combien de précipitations il tombe
donc ça c'est vraiment on est garant de
de cette information là on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir nous faisons
également des bulletins réguliers sur
sur ce sujet dans différents domaines
après nous avons bien sûr nous nous
développons des études et des recherches
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas parlé de
l'organisation dans le détail de Météo
France mais nous avons une direction de
la recherche c'est une des rares c'est
une des rares exceptions dans les
services météorologiques nous avons à
Météo France à la fois une école qui
forme aux ingénieurs une école de la
météorologie une école nationale de la
météorologie qui est basée à Toulouse
nous avons une direction de la recherche
avec environ 300 chercheurs également
basé à Toulouse
et puis bien sûr
l'anticipation et l'accompagnement des
situations de crise donc tu vas le
développer juste après au travers des
différents des différents activités
qu'on peut qu'on peut avoir donc
il y a un appui au service de l'État en
charge de la prévisions des crues et des
inondations alors j'ai changé mais je
crois que vous n'avez pas prévu
d'auditionner le chapi ou la DGPR le
chapitre c'est le service central
1 la théologie d'hydrométrologie d'appui
à la prévision des inondations donc qui
est basé à Toulouse sur sur le campus
Météo France d'ailleurs donc il y a une
étroite interaction avec le chapi et
Météo France donc ceci est cadré par une
convention cadre qui a été renouvelée
récemment en 2022 entre Météo France et
la DGPR donc c'est notamment également
au travers de cette convention que la
DGPR s'engage à nous financer le
programme radar bon j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure mais il y a beaucoup d'autres
choses qui sont qui sont prévues au
travers de cette convention j'ai cru
donc ces Météo France pardon
on est on est le porteur de Vigicrues au
travers de notre carte vigilance les
Vigicrues et les chapitres c'est ce
service central il y a une météo France
alors dans certains dans certains pays
les services météo intègrent
l'hydrologie la partie hydrologie en
France c'est séparé la pluviométrie au
domaine de Météo France et l'hydrologie
et du domaine du chapitre
il y a il y a du pour et du coup
voilà je resterai voilà non voilà il
faudra
oui oui on peut se poser la question on
s'est posé plusieurs fois la question du
coup si vous voulez dans le contexte à
la croisée des enjeux aujourd'hui
c'est quand même une interrogation
légitime
on s'est posé plusieurs fois la question
il y a eu des propositions un certain
moment mais elles n'ont pas
été suivies
débutants donc nous émettons des
bulletins réguliers quotidiens et
d'avertissement à destination de
services de prévision des crues alors
les services de prévision des crus ils
sont
rattachés ils sont animés
fonctionnellement par le chapitre mais
il dépendent pas hiérarchiquement du
chapitre ils sont en général rattachés à
des Dréal
j'ai fait une petite incidence il y a un
seul SPC service prévision des crus qui
est rattaché à Météo France c'est le SPC
medest historiquement et dans la cadre
de la politique de la DGPR actuellement
il y a une évolution de ce rattachement
qui est envisagée
pour faire en sorte que ce SPC ne soit
plus rattaché à Météo France mais à la
Dréal PACA
voilà donc il y a un dossier en cours
sur ce sujet
là bon je vais pas rentrer dans le
détail parce que c'est pas vraiment
l'objet de notre mais si vous voulez
vous en informer parce que vous en
entendrez peut-être parler dans un autre
biais voilà après sa question pour nous
l'organisation de la gestion de crise
aussi d'une manière générale
qui est un sujet aussi en soi il est
légitime que il y a forcément des
évolutions au travers à la fois des
événements
des vécus et on voit bien que il
faudrait aussi qu'il y ait une réflexion
pour voir comment on peut améliorer à la
fois la mutualisation de la connaissance
mais en même temps les méthodes les
process les outils et les niveaux
d'information et de communication qui
sont aussi des enjeux alors si vous
voulez poser la question tout à l'heure
de Vigicrues donc
déjà donc on travaille bien sûr
étroitement avec la dgpri encore une
fois et on a eu l'occasion d'affiner ce
dispositif entre
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une forte pluie
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une inondation
parfois quand il y a des crues soudaine
ben ça se rapproche beaucoup et donc on
on a on a dans le cadre de la vigilance
ben une partie qui est du ressort de
Météo France et dès que ça déborde en
gros des cours d'eau des bords et bien
c'est suivi par le chapitre et et les
chapitres au travers de sa visite rue
des avertissements vers le grand public
en ayant ce support de la carte de
vigilance Météo France et bien sûr quand
il fait ses quand il décide de mettre en
orange voir en rouge des des
départements ça a été fait en étroite
liaison en Météo France à partir des
données fournies par Météo France au
travers de ces bulletins les bulletins
réguliers ou d'avertissement donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle des BP des AP des
bulletins de précipitations et des
avertissements de précipitation qu'on
envoie régulièrement
au SAPI et aux différents services de
prévisions des crues
il faut savoir également qu'il y a
possibilité pour certains agents de
Météo France d'être affectés dans les
SPC ou chapit Jean-Michel fuirou et a eu
l'occasion de travailler au chapitre
également dans dans sa carrière voilà
bon information crue relayée sur la
carte de vigilance produite de France
ensuite appuie à la gestion de la
ressource en eau pour les services de
l'État au niveau national les
territorial et et on va le voir
Météo France est de plus en plus
sollicité parce que on voit que il y a
de plus en plus une problématique en
matière de ressources en eau liées aux
sécheresses
répétitives donc nous produisons là
aussi des bulletins des des services
opérationnels on contribue au Bulletin
de situations hydrologiques qui
s'appelle le BSH et on participe on
apporte notre expertise météorologique
pour différents instances de suivi
on met à disposition également un
extranet un extranet c'est un site
internet dédié accessible avec des mots
de passe mise à jour quotidiennement à
disposition de la dgln de la des Dréal
et des DDT
[Musique]
quand vous dites ressources ressources
en eau c'est à dire l'état des rivières
de ce qui est visible ou bien oui de ce
qui est visible
donc dans le cadre du je sais pas si
vous m'entendez donc oui voilà donc dans
le cadre de bulletin de situation
hydrologique il y a une répartition des
variables hydrologiques selon les
organismes et donc Météo France est en
charge du bilan des précipitations mais
aussi de l'humidité des sols et du stock
nival et ensuite donc les débits des
rivières sont suivis par les parler de
Real et également l'OSB à travers son
réseau en deux et le BRGM pour les eaux
souterraines donc c'est une c'est un
travail
multi-organisme partenarial et qui
apparaît dans l'obsh mais aussi dans le
comité d'anticipation de la situation
idéologique le cache au niveau national
donc de depuis
on apporte aussi un appui depuis 2015
vers la dgln et il y a une convention
cadre qui est renouvelée en 2022 qui qui
précise également les différents
services sur lesquels nous sommes
engagés
Jean-Michel vient d'y fait référence une
contribution régulière aux différentes
cellules interminées de crise sécheresse
je crois qu'il y en a une
ces jours-ci puisque on a préparé
l'argent c'est aujourd'hui il y a aussi
des cellules interministérielles et la
cellule interministrative
aujourd'hui il me semble il me semble
qu'on a eu donc on a quelqu'un qui va
faire une présentation pour un état des
lieux voilà donc ça on est amené à en
faire régulièrement dès qu'il y a une
cellule interne du Christ et puis bien
sûr il y a des cases qui sont plus
régulières
auxquels également on participe et on
contrib UE puisque on est une des
données d'entrée pour pour l'aide à la
décision ensuite
et donc simplement pour dire que tous
les
juste sur ce point là puisque le sujet
de des cellules de crise gestion de
crise est un sujet que nous abordons
bien sûr dans le cadre de la mission
d'information vous assistez jusqu'à quel
niveau
à tous les niveaux dès qu'il y a une
cellule départementale de crise vous
êtes en assistance jusqu'où vous allez
alors justement on va le voir pour les
la diapos suivantes va montrer mais on
reste d'abord sur cette diapo et puis on
va voir le détail en 2022 donc tout ça
pour dire que pendant cette année 2022
qui a été fortement impacté en matière
de ressources en eau et ben nous avons
été fortement sollicités fortement
sollicité justement à tous les niveaux
niveau départemental du niveau régional
et niveau et au niveau national
puisqu'il y a eu des effets combinés de
sécheresse de canicule et d'incendie de
forêt donc on peut passer la diap au
suivante à ce moment-là merci
voilà et justement ce qui s'est passé en
2022 quelques chiffres pour vous donner
une idée des sollicitations donc il y a
eu 132 mise à disposition du bulletins
hydrologique mensuel via le via le BSH
bulletin de suivi hydrologique
150 bon c'est un peu technique 150 mise
à disposition de bulletins hydrologique
au pas de temps décader via le BSH mais
surtout pour répondre à votre question
500 contributions au comité
départementaux de ressources en eau
entre le 3 février et le 15 novembre
2022 dont pour outre-mer trois comités
Polarion Cisco pour la Mayotte parce
qu'il y a également une première
également qui était concerné par cette
par cette année donc vous avez aussi une
répartition selon les selon les
départements entre
plus de vins comités et puis et puis peu
de comité alors je vous ai pas parlé de
je vous ai parlé de la diminution des
effectifs de Météo France mais je vous
ai pas parlé de l'évolution de
l'organisation territoriale de Météo
France en 2008 nous étions présents dans
chaque département ce qu'on appelait
départementaux météorologiques il y a
une décision qui a été de réduire le nom
le nombre de nos implantations
départementales c'est aussi c'était un
peu une exception française par rapport
aux autres aux autres pays il n'y avait
pas cette implantation voilà alors les
techniques évoluant et puis de toute
façon il fallait baisser les effectifs
également
voilà notre cible maintenant c'est 39
implantations donc vous voyez on est
passé de 108 implantations en métropole
je parle de que des implantations
métropoles à 30 39 implantations
vous imaginez toutes en disant vous
imaginez tout le travail de
réorganisation qu'il a fallu faire à
Météo France 90% des agences sont
fonctionnaires donc
ils sont voilà donc c'était au moment
des départs à la retraite qu'on voyait
comment on pouvait s'organiser donc on a
beaucoup développé aussi le travail à
distance pourquoi je vous parle de ça
parce que c'est pas neutres d'être
présent dans chacun des commodités des
départementaux des départements alors
qu'on est plus présents donc et bien on
fait en sorte de s'organiser quand même
donc l'organisation territoriale elle
est elle se base sur 7
cette interion cette vraiment centre
intérêts à partir de là on essaie de se
d'être présent et de rayonner alors on a
mis en place cette ce qu'on appelle des
directions internationales donc il y en
a une à Lille une à Strasbourg une à
Lyon une accès Aix-en-Provence une à
Bordeaux une
reine et puis une
je parle pas de Toulouse c'est le centre
c'est le centre opérationnel national et
et donc
plus comment on arrive à 39 vous allez
me dire mais après il y a des centres
des centres de rattachement aéronautique
nous avons 15 CRM donc voici Orly par
exemple pour une entité que deux les
plus importants et puis nous avons
également des petites pôles de
maintenance des petites unités de
maintenance qui nous permettent de
réparer les stations automatiques qui
nous permettent de réparer les radars et
là nous en avons 27 donc au total ça
fait à peu près 39 associations qui a
des centres qui des lieux géographiques
qui ont plusieurs fonctions voilà je
voulais vous aussi vous présenter
rapidement l'organisation territoriale
de Météo France et également pour être
présent dans ces comités départementaux
de ressources en eau bien nous avons mis
en place parce que le maillage il y a
quand même sur 7 centres intérêts
régionaux ils pouvaient être un peu un
peu un peu faible on a mis en place des
référents territoriaux qui permettent
d'être présent à moins de trois heures
de distance
département et donc
bonne partie de la présence de Météo
France c'est fait au travers de ces
référents territoriaux qui sont là pour
être à l'écoute des services
institutionnels et apporter toute
l'information qu'ils attendent également
donc ils sont employés à 100 % pour ces
ce type de mission voilà je crois que
il y en reste une on va passer la diapo
suivante pour me ce qui me concerne
voilà alors après bon on pourrait
développer mais je vais simplement vous
lister comme ça et différents services
météorologiques spécifiques certains
sont plus spécialement
dédiés à des activités commerciales donc
en matière d'hydrologie on a un service
qui s'appelle previlo en agro
météorologie on a des services un
système qui s'appelle isope c'est un peu
je vous donne ça comme ça après on
pourrait revenir en détail mais des on
fournit aussi des des flux de données
observés et prévu température
précipitations pour former des modèles
applicatifs de de différents entités qui
auraient besoin qui veulent qui
permettent de
il y a les bulletins je vous ai parlé
des bulletins mais il y a aussi des flux
de données qui permettent ensuite d'être
intégrés dans des modèles
on fournit bien sûr
quand vous dites fluide donner qui sont
intégrés dans les modèles notamment des
modèles applicatifs qui ont leur
économie propre du coup vous en tirez
une ressource aussi sur la gestion des
données oui alors
voilà alors
dans un autre débat vous savez que vous
avez tout à fait raison le débat des
données publiques données publiques ou
il y a une demande
je vais venir en général de de faire en
sorte que les services de l'État et les
établissements publics comme Météo
France mettent à disposition le plus
grand nombre de données
quel produit
et au travers d'une infrastructure donc
là nous avons cet objectif d'ici fin
2023 il y a déjà des choses qu'il y a
déjà un portail de données publiques qui
existent la météo France
il y a peut-être il est son ergonomie
peut être améliorée et donc c'est
là-dessus qu'on travaille pour pour
pour développer ses services là encore
dans les 58 et TP dont je vous ai parlé
il y a deux ATP qui nous ont été fournis
pour développer cette infrastructure
informatique pour faire en sorte que
voilà derrière parce que c'est bien de
pouvoir donner mettre à disposition des
données mais il faut que les flux soient
robuste quoi je veux dire qu'on puisse
que nous infrastructures puissent tenir
la science cette dimension est de plus
en plus importante tout à fait juste
pour bien vérifier à la croisée des
données vous avez bien bien sûr une
déclinaison au niveau territorial
jusqu'à quelle échelle à un moment donné
et ce qu'il y a un croisement entre des
échelles administratives et des échelles
géographiques c'est à dire que la
gestion de l'eau elle repose sur les
bassins versants bien évidemment et puis
il y a également des données qui
aujourd'hui sont agglomérées sont
croisés au niveau géographique voire
administratif par exemple au niveau des
régions etc donc vous avez ces
différentes mailles et les différents
niveaux d'organisation oui oui alors si
vous voulez en fait
d'abord la météo n'a pas de frontière et
donc au niveau de la France bien sûr on
a on a cette répartition géographique
territoriales et ainsi de tout ça mais
après on agrange tout ça au niveau
national donc
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
sur le réseau notre réseau de mesure
mais par exemple on a plus de 2000
sessions météorologiques au sol qu'on
entretient qui sont répartis sur le
territoire et qui pluviométrique nous
avons alors je suis jamais exactement
mais 33 radars je crois ou là aussi on
pourra vous expliquer un petit peu la
différence entre les radars et les
stations au sol mais où on peut avoir un
maillage précis et puis localisé ou pas
localisé comme on veut sur ce qu'on peut
appeler les lames d'eau c'est-à-dire
combien il a plus combien il est tombé
de précipitations un endroit précis
donné ou sur une ou sur un bassin
versant alors je sais pas si tu veux
compléter sur sur la partie dire aussi
que donc les flux de données c'est pas
que ce ne sont pas que des données
observées c'est aussi tes données
prévues voilà et que donc par exemple
sur notamment pour des EPTB puisqu'on
parle de gestion de l'eau ou des bureaux
d'études qui viennent à l'appui de petb
donc voilà donc il y a des flux de
données qui intègrent à la fois les
lamedo observées et les lames d'eau
prévu pour apporter un conseil sur la
gestion des étiages ou des éléments
comme ça voilà donc ça peut être aussi
ce type de d'information qui est tout à
fait essentiel pour améliorer la gestion
de l'eau et effectivement donc nos bases
de données elles n'ont pas ces
frontières administratives et donc on
peut les recomposer par rapport à votre
question selon la réalité le périmètre
du bassin versant à prendre en compte
sachant que ils sont d'une multitude
Sébastien versant en fonction donc de
critères qui sont pas uniquement
hydrologiques mais aussi très
administratif que donc voilà donc il
faut que voilà les bases de données
reconstituées ensuite donc les bons
périmètres pour les bons utilisateurs
c'est des sujets qui sont qui sont très
importants et ils vont l'aide de plus en
plus sur les soutiens des tirages
pouvoir anticiper au mieux pour savoir
combien de volume on va lâcher ça
devient des enjeux à la fois économiques
et à la fois des enjeux stratégiques
donc et puis après
l'amélioration de la connaissance sur
les modélisations de comportement des
bassins en fonction des niveaux
pluviométriques et de précipités
en termes d'analyse prospectives aussi
et ça devient également des sujets de
plus en plus puissants avec des
comportements aujourd'hui qui mais vous
nous en parlerez qui peuvent varier par
rapport au niveau de prospect au taux de
précipitation aux importances des
appréciations donc
c'est une de vos questions donc on y
répondra effectivement donc voilà et
regardez donc selon les échéances que ce
soit les échéances de la prévision
météorologique donc jusqu'à 10 à 15
jours et puis au-delà en sachant que
c'est plus les voilà c'est plus les
mêmes méthodes qui sont mis en oeuvre et
on a plus le même niveau de de fiabilité
c'est pas le même niveau d'information
que l'on peut apporter voilà donc ça
c'est une
une réalité finalement de la
prévisibilité de hydrologique en France
enfin en France et dans le monde voilà
parce que les moyens qui me sont alloués
aujourd'hui nous permettent de pouvoir
anticiper et de répondre et de nous
adapter ou est-ce que selon vous il
faudrait des moyens complémentaires pour
faire face aux en
jeux alors donc il y a on est sur des
projets de recherche aujourd'hui qui
trouve des applications opérationnelles
on pourrait citer par exemple nous on
est en appui du sméag le sméag c'est le
syndicat mixte d'étude et d'aménagement
de la Garonne donc je veux dire monsieur
gilet puisque donc on reste sur son
bassin de prédilection voilà donc par
exemple donc mettez France fournit des
prévisions saisonnières hydrologiques
donc d'évolution des débits de la
Garonne donc là on fait on donne des
prévisions à échéance de de trois mois
de 3 à 5 mois sur la Garonne pour
décider de la stratégie pour la gestion
des étiages et notamment à quel niveau
minimum de débit il faut que le Smeg
intervienne pour les hachés de barrage
donc on a c'est quelque chose qui est un
petit peu innovant on va dire chez nous
là-dessus donc ensuite dans les projets
de recherche et donc ça rejoint un petit
peu alors là dans le plan d'action qui a
été mis en oeuvre les différentes
mesures donc il y en a une mesure je
crois que c'est 49 ou quelque chose
comme ça enfin je les ai pas par cœur en
fait voilà donc qui
[Musique]
pourrait échanger un petit peu le
paysage
tout à fait je suis l'ancien président
du SMIC donc d'accord
j'ai bien suivi
mais
derrière c'était aussi toute la
négociation avec les concessions
hydroélectriques sur les stratégies de
ce qu'on appelle entre guillemets de
lachure
voilà et c'est absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui de conforter la connaissance
du modèle mais c'est assez spécifique à
nous regarde mais pas exclusivement
c'est pour ça que l'approche l'approche
prédictive et la qualité de l'approche
prédictive devient vraiment un enjeu
stratégique territorial à l'échelle de
chaque bassin en fait à tous les niveaux
chers collègues pas de question poursuit
ça va
la parole à Jean-Michel donc
et bien sûr on a on a on met en place
des services liés à l'impact du
changement climatique sur la ressource
en eau pourquoi parce que on a
l'historique l'historique de des
paramètres météo et on a également des
modèles participent notamment aux
travaux du siècle nous avons notre
équipe de recherche cela que dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure elle développe des
modèles de prévision à 50 100 ans et
donc on peut voir
ce continuum le passé et le futur tout à
l'heure ça vous sera présenté plus en
détail et donc on participe ainsi à
différents projets de recherche alors
explore 2 je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler là il faut et par exemple
et puis on met à disposition des
résultats parce que l'établissement
public Météo France ben comme je vous
l'ai dit il y avait en matière de
prévision il y a la vigilance important
de s'adresser directement au public mais
on a également des services relatifs au
changement climatiques et qui sont
également disponibles pour le grand
public alors vous avez
vous avez drillas le portail Dryas
et tout récemment nous avons mis en
place une rubrique eau de ce qu'on
appelle Dryas o qui est dédié justement
à les perspectives aux perspectives en
matière de d'évolution des bilans
ça me donne parce que il manque aussi un
point sur le changement climatique c'est
climat diag je sais pas si vous en avez
entendu parler de climatial vous tapez
climat diag sur Google vous arriverez à
climat direct et alors il y a climat
diag commune commune diag diagnostic
climat diagnostic des diag c'est elle
IMA diag faud faudra qu'on en rajoute à
la présentation parce que je pense c'est
important parce que c'est vous êtes vous
pouvez être élu dans vos dans vos dans
vos dans des communes et
vous tapez le nom de votre commune
êtes-vous vous avez un rapport d'une
douzaine de pages qui vous indique en
gros
l'évolution des paramètres à 50 ans
voilà donc c'est très pédagogique c'est
je veux dire ça donne je sais pas si tu
veux compléter un petit peu c'est mais
[Musique]
oui enfin voilà donc l'idée c'est de
permettre aux élus et aux citoyens
d'accéder facilement simplement à
l'évolution du climat sur sur leur
commune donc voilà donc c'est quelques
indicateurs
non on a fait un petit peu après la
démarrer donc ça a été présenté au Salon
des mers en novembre dernier non mais
c'est effectivement donc il y a encore
un effort de communication c'est pour ça
que donc on profite de toutes les
instances pour pour rappeler ce nouveau
service donc climat commune ça c'est un
peu grand public et puis il y a un
climat diag entreprise c'est à dire que
pour pour pour une entreprise qui
impactait un peu par les paramètres
météo et ben elle peut regarder alors là
c'est un peu plus compliqué et elle doit
renseigner plus de choses pour le
climata commune il suffit de renseigner
son numéro de commune pour qu'il m'a dit
à l'entreprise il faut répondre à un
petit questionnaire pour pour après voir
l'impact et pour aider l'entreprise à
anticiper un petit peu
certaines décisions à prendre par
rapport à son activité voilà qui m'a dit
à commune qui m'a dit à l'entreprise et
puis nous avons Dryas en fait Dryas
c'est c'est la base qui nous permet nous
a permis ensuite de développer ces
climatiales communes et climatiales
d'entreprise oui tout à fait qui sont
les mêmes données mais bon Dryas ça
s'adresse plutôt à des bureaux d'études
à des services techniques l'objectif
c'était de mettre à disposition les
données des projections climatiques donc
ce sont des gros volumes de données ça
nécessite donc avoir des services
techniques pour les traiter qui m'a dit
à commune c'est voilà ça s'adresse donc
aux élus à l'ensemble des citoyens qui
ont besoin d'avoir des informations
simples et puis territorialiser parce
que je crois que voilà pour se sentir
concerné il y a besoin que l'information
et le parle de son propre territoire
mal peut-être en réflexion parce que ça
sera intéressant d'avoir demain
après-demain un modèle un peu plus
standard d'informations de l'ensemble
des parties prenantes et plus
particulièrement des collectivités
locales et territoriales de telle
manière qu'on ait une forme de tableau
de bord qui soit un peu normalisée et
qui soit alimenté donc par des circuits
de données agrées et stabilisés sur ces
sujets là avec d'une manière plus
générale on va dire sur la gestion de la
ressource et des enjeux à risque
en tout cas il y a un sujet il y a un
sujet d'information parce que le risque
sinon c'est que chacun développe un peu
ses propres outils ses propres méthodes
etc
et sur les cellules PCs sur les cellules
les projets communaux de sauvegarde etc
c'est un des soucis c'est qu'on a
parfois des méthodologies de remontée ou
d'alerte par exemple qui sont qui sont
assez différenciés alors que peut-être
qu'on peut commencer à rentrer dans des
procédures un peu plus stabilisées un
peu plus communes et un peu plus
partagée vous voyez et ça va ensemble en
fait si on y regarde bien ça va ensemble
j'en profite parce que vous m'en donnez
l'occasion de faire référence également
à ce qui va se mettre en place
prochainement la formation des élus au
changement climatique je sais pas si
vous en avez entendu parler mais c'est
quelque chose qui avait été initié dans
l'Indre je crois par la préfecture de
l'Indre et
Notre Ministre Christophe Béchu a
souhaité généraliser ce type de
formation
à tous les élus donc il y a une
opération pilote qui doit se faire
incessamment sur trois départements
alors il croit qu'ils sont encore
confidentiels mais bon on les connaît et
ensuite ça va être généralisé à
l'ensemble des communes et Météo France
sera partie prenante au même titre que
l'OSB l'ADEME et le cerema donc il est
prévu que Météo France fasse une
présentation alors c'est bien cadré
parce que il faut le temps limité face
une présentation d'une demi-heure sur
sur le changement l'impact du changement
et notamment ça sera l'occasion de faire
la
promotion entre guillemets de climat
diag commune voilà donc voilà je voulais
simplement faire une parenthèse mais
effectivement ce que vous dites c'est
c'est vraiment important de se partager
l'information de pouvoir bien
communiquer de partager les mêmes bases
que ne pas laisser chacun
trouver les parce qu'il y a de une forte
demande une forte demande donc il faut
vraiment donner tous les outils pour
permettre de répondre à cette à cette
demande juste un point
parce que attention on peut faire
n'importe quoi
alors juste pour préciser aussi parce
que donc voilà donc la diapo donc on est
plus sur une rubrique eau on est
aujourd'hui sur un nouveau portail dries
a été ouvert le 30 mars 2023 qui vise
donc à mettre à disposition les données
des simulations hydrologiques donc le
Dryas le portail actuel c'était les
simulations sur le climat driasso c'est
le pendant de Dryas dans la même
présentation avec la même présentation
les mêmes formats mais pour les
simulations hydrologiques et donc ce
sont des simulations idéologiques qui ne
sont pas réalisées que par Météo France
elles sont réalisées dans le cadre du
projet national explore 2 donc en
collaboration donc avec l'inrae et le
berger aime notamment et ça veut dire
donc que les bureaux d'études et
finalement et tous les acteurs de
l'adaptation vont avoir progressivement
à partir de maintenant à disposition des
volumes de données très importantes sur
les futurs de l'eau donc voilà alors
peut-être donc ça reste à ce stade là
encore ça s'adresse à des services
techniques comme on a dit mais en tout
cas donc les données sur le futur de
l'eau vont devenir largement afin elles
vont devenir largement accessibles à
toute un ensemble d'acteurs et que donc
il y a beaucoup de réflexion sur
l'accompagnement des acteurs que ce soit
dans nos projets là il faut et climat et
dans le projet explore 2 voilà et donc
on est quand même sur un changement de
j'allais dire de paradigme sur la
distribution des données futures de
l'eau je pense que c'est intéressant de
le noter peut-être dans dans vos travaux
donc sur l'aspect changement climatique
et donc Météo France joue ce rôle
fédérateur finalement dans la
distribution des données pour proposer
une même interface d'accès aux données
que ce soit pour le climat ou que ce
soit pour pour l'eau parce qu'en fait
les deux sujets sont liés je pense que
vous l'avez que ça vous apparaît
clairement
alors donc dans la suite de la
présentation donc j'ai repris des
diapositives que j'avais donc pour le
séminaire de sur la gemapi qui avait
lieu ce matin donc que le sénateur gilet
faisait l'introduction et comment je
faisais une première présentation sur
les changements climatiques dans le
domaine de l'eau alors donc j'ai piocher
quelques diapositives parce que j'ai vu
que dans le questionnaire vous avez
beaucoup de questions sur les aspects
quels ressources en eau à l'horizon 2050
en France alors l'idée c'est pas
forcément de suivre l'intégralité des
diapositives pour garder suffisamment de
temps d'échange mais peut-être juste
voilà on peut en piocher quelques unes
ou peut-être donc vous voyez celle qui
vous intéresse particulièrement donc
dans votre présentation monsieur gilet
vous avez évoqué donc l'aspect
exceptionnel de l'amener 2022 donc qui à
la fois donc qui correspond à une année
moyenne de du milieu de siècle quand
même dans les dans les simulations
climatiques et donc elle est
complètement hors norme par rapport à
notre climat d'aujourd'hui et donc je le
rappelle ici donc voilà une deux degrés
7 de réchauffement par rapport à 61 90
on est près de degré près de 3 degrés
par rapport au début du 20e siècle donc
voilà et puis donc en termes d'évolution
de liverpo transpiration aussi donc
c'est toujours la barre de droite et
donc elle est elle est au-dessus de tout
ce que l'on a connu donc là c'est des
moyennes nationales si on le regardait
dans certaines régions donc les écarts
sont encore pire et on réchauffement en
France qui s'approche quand même assez
rapidement des deux degrés donc en
intégrant l'année 2022 c'est un degré 7
quand on regarde donc la part entropique
expliqué par le changement climatique
parce qu'il y a aussi de la variabilité
naturelle mais mais quand même donc
voilà donc des ordres de grandeur qu'il
faut commencer à voir en tête juste pour
mes collègues sur les feux hors normes
les les
DLCI et les services incendie parlent
toujours de la règle des 30-30 plus de
30 degrés moins de 30% de taux
d'humidité et le dernier d'ailleurs
le dernier c'est le vent et en 2022 on a
explosé évidemment cette cette règle là
donc tous les tous les paramètres
étaient
largement dans le rouge et ce qui
explique aussi le degré d'inflammabilité
et la violence des flammes parce qu'en
fait ces feux sont aussi particuliers
dans leur violence de propagation et le
fait qu'on ne peut pas une fois qu'ils
sont partis on dit fort norme mais c'est
la très grande difficulté de pouvoir les
arrêter compte tenues de la violence
donc quand on est sur des climatologies
de ce type ben voilà le résultat qui
arrive à un moment donné
absolument
donc voilà
qu'on parle des précipitations et
peut-être que ce qui est important à
avoir en tête c'est que les territoires
ne vivent pas aujourd'hui exactement les
mêmes transitions dans le domaine de
l'eau et ça sera également vrai dans le
futur que la France est dans une zone de
transition climatique qu'aujourd'hui
donc quand on fait une moyenne au niveau
national des précipitations on ne voit
pas de tendance depuis les années 60 par
contre donc quand on redescend donc à
l'échelle donc des régions ou des
stations on a donc c'est la carte de
droite on a donc sur une moitié nord de
la France une majorité de tendance à la
hausse sur les précipitations au niveau
national parce que les précipitations au
niveau annuel pardon excusez moi et par
contre sur la moitié sud une majorité de
tendance à la baisse et donc dans le
tableau qui est à gauche on retrouve les
différentes régions donc c'est Bretagne
Normandie Pays de Loire centre
donc il de France ou de France Grand Est
Bourgogne Franche-Comté Auvergne
province elle peut Côte d'Azur Occitanie
nouvelle-aquitaine et Corse voilà et
donc les canton d'un triangle vert ça
veut dire qu'on a une majorité de de
station qui sont à la hausse et quand on
a un triangle jaune c'est qu'elles sont
majoritaires mal à baisse et puis la
première ligne ce sont les années et les
quatre lignes suivantes ce sont les
quatre saisons et on voit voilà que les
régions du nord de la France donc qui
sont début de liste
en plus de triangles verts et puis les
régions du sud de la France qui arrivent
en seconde partie elles ont plus de
triangles jaunes on voit aussi que l'on
n'a pas toujours des signaux
parfaitement établis donc le les
précipitations sont aussi sensibles à
une variabilité décennale sur notre
territoire on n'a pas des tendances
aussi claires sur les précipitations que
ce que l'on a sur les températures il
faut l'avoir en tête la variabilité
aussi d'une année sur l'autre que le que
l'on a vécu
que l'on vit en permanence mais que 2022
nous a rappelé voilà donc elle est plus
marquée sur les précipitations que sur
les que sur les températures
sur la diapositive suivante donc on
parlait des extrêmes et des extrêmes sur
les pluies intenses et des extrêmes sur
la sécheresse des sols dans les deux cas
on a aujourd'hui donc des signaux sur
l'aggravation donc de ces phénomènes
extrêmes donc le diagramme de donc de
gauche c'est les plus extrêmes sur les
régions méditerranéennes donc là il y a
eu des publications et qui ont
prouvé montrer donc cette aggravation de
l'intensité de ces précipitations
extrêmes mais il n'y a pas que les
régions méditerranéennes qui sont
concernées aujourd'hui on a aussi la
Bretagne le centre le nord-est et en
fait dans d'autres régions
du point de vue statistique on peut pas
affirmer que le phénomène est en cours
ça veut pas dire qu'il est pas en course
ça veut dire que il y a des règles
statistiques pour arriver à le à le
démontrer qu'il y a de la variabilité
naturelle dans ces événements
aujourd'hui on peut pas le démontrer du
point de vue statistique mais il est
vraisemblable que cette dynamique
d'aggravation des événements extrêmes
des plus intenses elle est en oeuvre
sûrement sur l'ensemble du territoire et
en parallèle et c'est complètement
cohérent avec ce que a dit le GIEC dans
son dernier dans le sixième rapport
d'évaluation on a une aggravation des
sécheresses des sols la convention donc
au niveau national donc elles ont été
multipliées par deux en termes de
fréquence de prise en année 60 dans
d'autres régions du sud de la France
donc la partie sud de la nouvelle
Aquitaine l'Occitanie particulièrement
et puis ensuite donc province à la Côte
d'Azur on est plutôt sur des ratios de 3
aujourd'hui en termes en termes
d'aggravation de l'intensité et de la
fréquence des séchage
pardon
excusez-moi c'est oui donc vous avez
raison donc ça pose la question donc de
l'observation alors donc pour l'humidité
des sols on n'utilise pas on n'a pas
directement de l'observation on utilise
en fait de la modélisation donc ce sont
donc des modèles on va dire
hydrologiques qui sont opérés en temps
réel qui ont été calibrés par des
campagnes de mesure qui sont qui sont
suivis également en termes avec un
monitoring parce qu'on a quelques points
de mesure d'humidité des sols au niveau
national on en a une vingtaine à peu
près et qui nous servent à faire donc
monitoring pour vérifier que c'est
cohérent avec les mesures que l'on
établit à partir de modélisation mais
c'est les données ce sont des données
analysées ce sont pas des données
observées celles qui sont utilisées on a
des rétrospectives donc j'ai reçu avec
ces modèles depuis le début des années
60 qui même 58 à peu près et donc ça
nous permet d'avoir une estimation ou
pas de temps quotidien et à une
résolution de 8 km sur le territoire de
l'humidité des sols et c'est à partir de
là que avec on définit des critères d'un
événement de sécheresse et donc
notamment c'est l'idée d'avoir un
événement qui a un temps de retour qui
dépasse 10 ans c'est ce qui nous
déclenche le fait que
du côté exceptionnel donc de la
sécheresse des sols
donc dire poursuivante donc c'était en
termes de ressources en eau il y a un
indicateur qui est souvent utilisé qui
est très simple c'est l'écart entre les
précipitations et les vapo transpiration
alors il faut se méfier parce que les
vapres transpiration il y a plusieurs
formules possibles et donc ce que je
vous montre là donc c'est un côté
peut-être un petit peu effrayant enfin
en tout cas bon mais peut-être on est
dans l'esprit de de votre de votre
audition puisque enfin notre audition
puisque là donc on voit qu'on commence
en 2022 en intégrant 2022 donc on a
rr-etp qui deviennent négatif pour la
première fois en moyenne décennale sur
la France mais bon ça dépend quelle
formule développée transpiration on
utilise mais on voit bien en tout cas
donc la ligne rouge c'est une moyenne
décennale et on voit donc cette baisse
régulière donc très forte depuis les
années 80 avec bien sûr quelques
variabilités et puis l'année 2022
complètement à droite qui est un hors
saint complet dans la série donc où on a
un écart là qui dépasse 300 mm entre les
précipitations qui ont été recueillies
donc sur de la France une moyenne
nationale et l'évapotranspiration
exceptionnelle qui ont été vécues donc
quand on a en même temps un événement de
déficit de précipitation et de fortes
chaleurs donc avec donc qui se traduit
par des vapot transpiration bien on se
retrouve dans des situations tout à fait
exceptionnelles et donc ça illustre
aussi finalement la du point de vue de
l'aléa la singularité de l'année 2022 et
son caractère exceptionnel peut-être que
j'anticiper que vous allez le l'exprimer
ou le projeter mais du coup la
cartographie qui nous permettrait de
croiser en même temps les évolutions
climatologiques et les évolutions de la
ressource serait aussi particulièrement
intéressant c'est à dire que sur la
cartographie précédente si on l'a croisé
avec l'évolution même de la ressource
c'est-à-dire des stocks et l'analyse des
stocks puisque les territoires se
comportent aussi différemment même si on
a une pluviométrie qui reste
relativement importante sur certains
territoires ça peut aussi malgré tout
avoir des impacts contenus des
caractéristiques de effectivement du
territoire donc on a la pluviométrie
mais l'évolution en même temps de la
ressource en eau qui se croisent et ça
c'est donner là vous les avez elles sont
croisées il y en a un grand nombre de
données donc et on peut en fabriquer de
nouvelles donc je l'ai pas donc je pense
que vous voudriez une carte spatialisée
de cette évolution RER - et TP montrer
des tendances sur c'était ça l'idée de
je suis pas sûr d'avoir 170 2022 on
pourrait mettre des tendances à
l'échelle nationale au niveau des
évolutions des températures etc vous
apporter une cartographie qui est assez
précise sur les évolutions à l'échelle
du territoire national si on croise
aussi avec l'évolution des stocks et de
la ressource en eau
c'est pas forcément homogène non mais
tout à fait donc
on l'a sur l'humidité des sols par
exemple on a des diagnostics sur
l'humidité des sols qui montrent qu'on a
des comportements voilà très différents
je vous l'ai dit entre les régions du
sud de la France les régions du Nord
après bon c'est important aussi de
regarder les tendances des territoires
parce que donc il y a une question
peut-être sur la résilience il y a des
territoires qui sont habitués à
connaître des événements extrêmes comme
la Méditerranée parce que elle a un
climat plus aride naturellement elle est
peut-être mieux préparée enfin ça ça
peut être des réflexions et on a vu en
particulier que les sécheresses à
répétition dans le grand est depuis 2018
ont provoqué alors beaucoup de dégâts
sur la biodiversité sur la forêt donc il
y a beaucoup de rapport là-dessus moi
j'étais intervenu auprès de d'organismes
forestiers
sur l'habitat donc il y a les retrait
gonflement des argiles et donc sur des
territoires qui étaient moins habitués à
rencontrer les sécheresses donc on a
aussi éventuellement donc des
conséquences qui peuvent être très
fortes donc il y a un petit peu c'est il
y a le côté l'intensité de la Léa et
puis il y a le côté un peu plus
exceptionnel je pense sur des
territoires qui n'ont pas rencontrés
jusqu'à présent de ces phénomènes-là et
qui sont c'est un petit peu comme pour
les feux de forêt qui sont confrontés un
petit peu pour la première fois à des
événements qui ne qui ne connaissaient
pas et donc moi c'était un peu dans les
réflexions là que j'ai conclu comme ça
ma présentation sur sur la gemapi donc
insister sur le futur des événements
extrêmes qui ne peut pas être extrapolé
à partir seulement des relevés passés et
donc jusqu'à présent donc la politique
de prévention des risques elle
s'appuyait sur la meilleure connaissance
donc des événements passés et donc
aujourd'hui il faut bien sûr conserver
cette mémoire mais c'est pas suffisant
parce que les événements du futur et
bien ils seront différents ils pourront
être différents de ce qu'on a connu dans
le passé
donc après j'allais sur des éléments
concernant le changement climatique donc
peut-être on peut passer sur la façon
dont on construit les projections
climatiques mais voilà donc c'était de
dire que il y a il y a un gap entre le
fait que les services que les les
services de recherche les laboratoires
qui travaillent sur la recherche du
climat et réaliser des simulations et
puis tout le travail qui a à faire pour
que ça devienne des données pour les
services climatiques et voilà c'est de
dire ne pas sous-estimer ce temps le
temps de la recherche qui ensuite qui
est ensuite le temps qu'il faut pour en
construire des services climatiques et
voilà donc c'était de rappeler tout le
travail qu'il y a derrière en aval qui
mobilise donc des ressources on a
beaucoup parlé des ressources en début
de
nos discussions voilà et puis un travail
aussi Qui est qui amène à de la de la
collaboration entre entre les différents
partenaires parce que dans le domaine de
l'eau aujourd'hui c'est voilà c'est
c'est plusieurs organismes qui
interviennent c'est pas un seul
organisme et donc voilà donc voilà
peut-être sur développer sur ce plan là
parce que
l'approche aujourd'hui à la fois
consolider sous forme aussi de
groupements de compétences le fait de de
travailler de consolider les réseaux à
la fois d'analyses de partage tout ça
effectivement on va plutôt dans le bon
sens mais est-ce que vous avez des
préconisations à faire sur ce sujet là
est-ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui
peut-être des propositions qui nous
seraient utiles pour améliorer le
système qui existe sur le plan national
on s'aperçoit que sur la recherche
fondamentale et la recherche appliquée
d'une manière générale au niveau de
l'eau
il nous semblerait qu'il faudrait un peu
plus de lisibilité quand même qui a
quand même un patchwork qui est quand
même relativement important mais ça peut
être tout à fait subjectif quel est
votre avis donc en termes de recherche
donc il y a des programmes exploratoires
pour la recherche les PEPR donc voilà
dans l'état donc vient de mettre donc
des budgets importants pour développer
donc
la connaissance sur un certain nombre de
domaines
stratégiques et alors donc il y a un
Pepa sur le climat qui s'appelle le
tracs qui a démarré donc
qui a fait son sa réunion de lancement
au mois de mars
on parle aussi du PEPR one water c'est
donc le One water c'est le Pr qui elle
qui parle de l'eau donc Météo France et
très impliqué d'entraxe sur le climat
Météo France participe aussi au one
water sur l'eau donc le point
d'attention par rapport à ces programmes
exploratoires c'est que c'est qu'il soit
pas en silo puisque le climat est d'un
côté l'eau est dans notre côté les
risques il y a une autre bepr qui
s'appelle arrimage je crois enfin je
peux voilà il y en a un sur la forêt
donc aujourd'hui donc finalement les
communautés se rassemblent mais par
contre il faut vérifier que elle se
parle aussi entre communautés
et puis
peut-être donc
si on prend l'exemple du projet explore
2 qui est dessiné pour amél la mettre à
jour les connaissances sur les
évolutions les futurs de l'eau
ce projet ce programme national il a eu
du je pense qu'on peut dire qu'il a eu
du mal à émerger que depuis entre export
de 1070 qui avait eu lieu en 2013 qui
s'était fini en 2013 et le montage
d'explor 2 donc un projet qui a démarré
en 2021 il s'est passé 8 ans donc on
voit qu'il y a une difficulté peut-être
à avoir des financements il pourra voir
un soutien de l'État continue et je
crois que peut-être donc en tout cas il
y a la réflexion de dire que après
explore 2 on attend de pas de nouveau 8
ans pour réorganiser quelque chose qu'on
arrive sur un flux un peu plus continué
de mise à jour des connaissances et donc
dans lequel la puissance publique a
sûrement un rôle majeur à jouer
pour pour que c'est ses services de
puisse être ensuite donc que ça me
permet l'action au niveau des
territoires
on a pu voir au niveau de certaines
agences de l'eau conduire un moment
donné des études et des analyses et
parfois sur des référentiels qui étaient
un peu différents qui étaient pas
toujours partagées
dans sa question je vous rejoins je vous
rejoins en tout cas nous voilà que nous
en tant qu'organisme national c'est vrai
que
on est plus à l'aise lorsqu'il y a des
démarches qui sont coordonnées et
lorsqu'on a des démarches plus
singulières au niveau des régions qui
sont liées aussi parce que elles ont des
peuvent avoir des enjeux particulières
de remise à jour des stages ou d'autres
enjeux des plantes d'adaptation qui sont
un peu dictées par les des éléments donc
de stratégie qui sont qui leur sont
demandées mais c'est vrai que lorsque
c'est anticipé et coordonné au niveau
national je pense que c'est plus robuste
en tout cas nous pour un organisme comme
Météo France et plus facile aussi
inscrire
donc pardon peut-être on peut pas rester
sur cette diapositives là donc les
températures qui montent je pense que ça
ça vous a voilà peut-être aller sur les
précipitations parce qu'il y a un
message sur les précipitations de dire
qu'il y a des incertitudes sur les
précipitations donc il faut avoir en
tête que la France est dans une zone de
transition climatique et que donc
aujourd'hui donc
sur les précipitations au niveau
national on a pratiquement autant de
simulations climatiques qui nous
annoncent une hausse qui ne que celle
qui nous annonce une baisse et on voit
le et que la dispersion finalement elle
est assez importante parce que donc à
l'horizon 2050 de si on finalement donc
selon les simulations qu'on peut
regarder on peut aller entre -10 et +10
% sur le sur la ressource en nous et
c'est donc ça c'est c'est pas du tout la
même réalité au niveau des territoires
il faut prendre le sujet que beaucoup
d'humilité encore à l'heure actuelle
parce que la complexité fait que c'est
très délicat aujourd'hui de pouvoir être
prédictif donc
voilà alors donc je quand je dis ça je
vais pas m'arrêter là parce que sinon ce
serait un peu dogue donc il y a quand
même donc des signaux dont on peut se
saisir pour ensuite le traduire dans le
terme d'action d'adaptation sur les
territoires donc ce sont par exemple les
évolutions saisonnières qui montrent que
l'on a quand même donc une majorité de
hausse qui sont en hiver et par contre
donc un signal de baisse l'été et donc
la signale de baisse l'été mais ça nous
amène sur une quasi certitude sur la
gravation des sécheresses des sols donc
des événements tel qu'on a connu l'été
2022 cela il s'inscrivait bien à la
lignée de de ce que nous indique les
changements climatiques je rappelle
aussi dans une diapo de le petit coin
cette carte elle montre belle rappelle
que les tendances ne sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes entre le Nord et le Sud
de la France qu'il y a des territoires
que qu'on s'attend quand même toujours à
voir le nord de la France un peu plus
privilégié en termes de quantité
précipitations par rapport aux régions
du sud ça veut dire que donc les
territoires vont avoir à s'adapter à des
réalités hydrologiques qui vont être
différentes alors qui peut être
différente aussi par rapport à leur
propre vulnérabilité par rapport aux
enjeux du territoire mais par rapport en
termes d'aléa donc les évolutions clim
atiques les trajectoires afin ou les
trajectoires climatiques et
hydrologiques vont pas être tout à fait
face à nos pas tout à fait identique sur
le territoire et donc il y a sûrement
pas une mesure d'adaptation nationale
identique et donc chacun va devoir
composer selon des réalités du
changement climatique qui vont être qui
vont être différentes juste si vous
voulez soit diapo suivante
la population
si on doit faire en fonction de de son
département et de sa situation
géographique et pourtant si vous voulez
aujourd'hui je pense que la population a
besoin d'une information claire et on
doit l'informer par rapport à l'eau oui
donc il faut que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez mettre au point vous mettez au
France est-ce que est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une carte qui va être de lecture
facile pour monsieur tout le monde qui
regarde la météo tous les matins en
prenant son petit déjeuner j'en connais
chez moi mais vous voyez il y a besoin
de il y a besoin d'une lecture facile
je vais pas faire de promotion d'une
chaîne par rapport à d'autres mais je
sais pas si vous avez vu mais France 2 a
mis en place un bulletin météo et climat
maintenant le soir auquel on contribue
donc avec
régulièrement des interviews d'experts
je sais pas si toi tu étais pas encore
l'occasion de d'intervenir mais je pense
que ça pourrait avoir sa place là c'est
à dire de montrer peut-être faire
attention parce que très vite ça peut
être complexe comme vous le dites que
le téléspectateur dans dans de chez lui
il faut quand même des des discours
relativement faciles à comprendre
et on arrive très vite dans une certaine
complexité mais je pense qu'il y a
matière il y a matière à utiliser au
moins ce support et je sais que TF1 veut
faire également un peu la même chose
donc en utilisant les médias et à
déguiseur de grande écoute
régionale
mais quand on dit quand on dit France TV
c'est aussi France 3
et puis donc il y a
ecovoit de l'eau donc qui est évoquée
donc un nouveau service et dans lequel
donc quand voilà sur ce type de service
donc Météo France et sollicité pour
fournir des informations donc à des
échelles locales des échelles
départementales sur l'humidité des sols
sur les précipitations et donc je sais
pas exactement encore quelle sera la
forme de ce service qui est bon enfin je
pense que le
on vient d'avoir une sollicitation
toute récente
ce sujet qui donc
c'est quoi le service c'est
de l'eau et quoi de l'eau c'est ça et il
se tait pas à mettre en place un service
spécifique mais se reposer sur les
services qui pouvaient être existants et
déjà
largement diffusé dont l'application
Météo France donc on est en train de
regarder comment on pourrait intégrer
leurs données les flux de données pour
que au travers notre application météo
France qui est quand même pas mal
consulté
transmettre être un vecteur de cette
information aussi et vous avez raison il
faut vraiment que
la communication c'est hyper important
et il faut trouver les bons vecteurs
pour passer les bons messages et mon
message sachant que ils sont pas
forcément nationaux il y a une il y a
des déclinaisons régionales voilà
et donc en fait donc s'il y a des
réalités différentes qui vont être
vécues au niveau des territoires par
contre tout le monde aura affaire des
efforts et que donc quelque part la
ressource en eau elle diminue partout
donc voilà donc il y a quand même une il
y a quand même voilà et donc ce message
là donc il est vrai partout voilà mais
voilà et puis et je pense qu'il faut
l'amener aussi sur la réalité des des
territoires parce que donc en restait
juste aux variables atmosphériques qui
sont en entrée du cycle de l'eau c'est
pas suffisant parce que donc certains
territoires bénéficient de nappes qui
sont on va dire plus facile à exploiter
certains disposent de retenue qui
peuvent être exploitées d'autres ne les
ont pas voilà donc il y a ensuite donc
des informations sur
la réalité de la ressource en eau des
territoires qui qui sont qui sont
différentes donc voilà donc c'est vrai
que il y a des données d'entrée qui
viennent donc des simulations
climatiques et hydrologiques là
également les hydrologique qui vont être
réalisés et qui sont réalisés dans le
cadre du projet explorer et qu'on va
mettre à disposition sur le portail
driasso on est un hydrologie naturelle
donc on intègre pas les usages donc
après c'est le travail à faire par les
EPTB par les clés par les les
collectivités à la compétence gemapi
donc de d'aller croiser les usages et
leurs évolutions par rapport à
l'évolution de la ressource en eau
naturelle
peut-être juste faire un stop and go sur
le sur ce sujet là
le but du jeu d'abord c'est d'améliorer
tous les systèmes de connaissances à
l'échelle des bassins versants et donc
vraiment d'essayer de les perfectionner
en termes de connaissances bien sûr de
la ressource et de connaissances des
usages plus fine possible donc des
consommations puisque le dialogue
politique
sera de plus en plus puissant étangible
à l'échelle des bassins versants sur la
répartition de la ressource
donc il faut que ce modèle tienne et
soit le plus solide possible à terme et
c'est ce modèle là qui va baser quelque
part
les éléments la méthode de négociation
de répartition de la ressource à
l'échelle d'un bassin versant
et derrière c'est la répartition de ce
modèle ça veut dire que chacun doit
s'engager en même temps sur des
démarches à la fois de propriété ou
d'évolution de ces process pour être le
plus performant le plus sobre possible
en essayant de limiter en même temps ces
consommations mais en ayant néanmoins
dans le cadre de cette vision une forme
de garantie de ressources permettant une
vision plus réelle
donc c'est ça ce qui va se passer pour
tout le monde et donc ça il faut le
consolider à toutes les étapes c'est
pour ça que la modélisation de la
connaissance à la croisée de l'ensemble
des enjeux est absolument essentiel
aujourd'hui à l'échelle des bassins dans
cette dimension de partage enfin c'est
ce que j'affirme moi depuis un certain
temps mais je pense que vous partagez
mes collègues cette démarche là qui est
déjà en route on est bien d'accord mais
qui nécessite encore des
approfondissements on s'aperçoit que par
exemple aujourd'hui
la connaissance véritablement des usages
c'est à dire des prélèvements n'est pas
aussi fine qu'on le croit loin s'en fout
donc si si on veut vraiment évoluer sur
le sujet il va falloir aller plus vite
plus fort véritablement là dessus même
sur la ressource au niveau des stocks et
notamment sur les nappes profondes on
s'aperçoit que on ne connaît pas tout
loin s'en fout voilà c'est à titre
d'exemple mais pour ça permet de cadrer
un peu aussi globalement avec vous même
si c'est pas des données que nous
mobilisons Météo France donc dans les
réunions auxquelles on participe on sait
bien qu'aujourd'hui la connaissance des
usages donc et loin d'être aussi avancé
que que la connaissance de l'hydrogène
naturel
oui non c'était une observation parce
que je suis évidemment d'accord avec ce
que vient de dire Hervé mais j'ai des
souvenirs quand tu es écologiste à le
souvenir du climatossepticisme des
questions qui fait froid bah tu vois
bien qu'il y a pas de réchauffement
climatique et donc il y a une grande
variabilité sur l'eau il y a une grande
variabilité des prévisions que vous vous
nous montrez et des différenciations
régionales mais il y a aussi des
dynamiques qui elles sont plus affirmées
sur sur les évolutions de température
sur la baisse et il y a une réticence
enfin moi je le nalyse comme ça sur la
question des usages c'est-à-dire qu'au
fond ceux qui ont des usages aujourd'hui
préfèrent ne pas enfin ne pas trop les
mettre sous les radars parce qu'on sait
qu'il va y avoir une bataille sur la sur
la sur la ressource voilà c'était juste
un commentaire c'est à dire que je pense
que dans la publication citoyenne dans
la compréhension je pense qu'il faut que
les données scientifiques soient le
mieux partagé mais tout en étant
compréhensible il faut que les
dynamiques soient perceptibles ce jeu je
me rappelle d'un grand ministre enfin
d'un grand ministre d'un ministre qui
mettait en doute les dérèglements
climatiques et qui a fait beaucoup de
dégâts et qui peut nous faire prendre
beaucoup de retard et quand on comprend
les dynamiques on s'attache à anticiper
les conséquences sans doute mieux et
c'est ce que Météo France nous aide à
faire sur y compris sur les îlots de
chaleur urbain sur enfin moi j'ai
beaucoup travaillé avec vos données par
exemple sur la métropole du Grand Paris
pour montrer à quel point on était
touché par les ICU enfin d'accord qui
peut nous rassurer c'est que le ministre
en question est plutôt mal fini mais
je vous redonne la parole pour moi juste
c'est pour dire que que l'année 2022
elle nous montre aussi donc l'importance
de prendre en compte les les la
variabilité naturelle voilà et de dire
qu'on peut pas s'adapter qu'à la moyenne
sur 30 ans et que quand un climat futur
il continu à avoir donc des années plus
humides des années plus sèches et la
difficulté c'est comment on arrive à
gérer à la fois les années sèches et les
années chaudes et donc cette année 2022
bon bah c'est ça sera une année moyenne
de l'année de la décennie future mais
assez décennies là il y aura aussi des
années alors plus sèches encore pas
forcément puisque donc d'aller
simulations l'année des sécheresses de
niveau 2022 en tout cas donc on a peu de
simulation qui sont capables de faire
des années plus sèches donc sous réserve
que nos simulations soient soit
correctes donc en termes de d'anomalie
de sécheresse on s'adapte pas forcément
à avoir des années excessivement plus
sèches plus sèches en été oui mais pas
forcément plus sèche sur le bilan annuel
par contre donc des années beaucoup plus
chaudes et donc voilà donc il faut
s'adapter non pas la moyenne mais il
faut s'adapter aux événements extrêmes
et donc voilà donc ça c'est mettre une
leçon de 2022
donc moi j'avais je vous propose de
d'aborder les questions alors que vous
souhaitez aborder enfin nous on y
répondra bien sûr à votre questionnaire
mais s'il y avait des points que vous
lui regardez au préalable peut-être
c'était très intéressant et encore une
fois
merci
vous avez répondu déjà à un certain
nombre de questionnons qui étaient posés
on a parlé des systèmes d'information
à ce niveau là sur les modèles
prédictifs
alors on voit que les cycles de
sécheresse aussi sont de plus en plus
longs est-ce que ce sont des éléments
que vous constatez ou pas pas vraiment
en fait d'accord non ce que l'on observe
c'est que avec des températures plus
élevées les déficits de précipitation
conduisent à des sécheresses de manière
plus précoce et de manière plus intense
que l'on passe très vite avec des
températures élevées on passe très vite
d'une situation
d'excédent de l'humidité des sols à une
situation de sécheresse alors il y a une
année récente qui était incroyable ou en
un mois je sais plus quelle région de
France c'était on était passé du record
de de sol le plus humide au record de
sol le plus sec parce que pendant un
mois il avait fait tellement chaud que
on avait finalement que le sol avait
complètement évaporé l'eau dont il
disposée donc on a une plus grande
variabilité volatilité peut-être de
cette ressource en eau mais pour autant
quand on regarde donc on a plus de
sécheresse des sols mais on n'a pas plus
de variabilité des précipitations en
fait ou du moins aujourd'hui on n'est
pas capable de le démontrer
des pépris notamment sur nos
départements on se rend compte que les
services sont de plus en plus strictes
et vont bien au-delà de ce qui était
historiquement la crue centennale et que
c'est pas toujours bien vécu parce que
effectivement
ça met des communes en grande difficulté
moi dans mon département j'ai tout un
secteur qui est la vallée de la Vézère
qui est qui est très touché dans le
tourisme va être beaucoup touché parce
qu'effectivement il y a un pépèrei qui
si vous y rajoutez une couche avec
Lausanne vous ce sont des des
départements enfin des secteurs de
départements qui vont plus avoir du tout
d'évolution donc je pense que tout ça se
justifie par ces phénomènes qui vont
être de plus en plus violents et de plus
en plus rare mais de plus en plus
violent au niveau de la pluviométrie
ça vous le valider donc oui donc oui je
devais avoir une diapositive sur les
précipitations extrêmes voilà donc si
vous voulez donc effectivement oui cette
réalité en tout cas donc de dire que les
précipitations extrêmes deviennent plus
intenses alors la façon dont se traduit
dans le cycle de l'eau en termes de
d'inondation c'est un travail qui reste
à faire donc là on parle que de la
précipitation intense les phénomènes
d'inondation se sont des phénomènes qui
sont complexes et différents types
d'inondations il y a du ruissellement
urbain il y a des débordements de cours
d'eau qui ou lorsque l'eau est aggloméré
donc à l'échelle du bassin versant un
rôle de concentrateur on a des crues qui
sont liés de la fonte des neiges on a
des crues liés à des débordements de
nappes donc on a une multiplicité de
phénomènes d'inondation qui ne peuvent
pas se résumer simplement à
l'augmentation des précipitations
intenses on a des phénomènes qui peuvent
venir s'inverser les sols sont plus sec
et donc ça peut donc peut-être ils
absorbe de l'eau en début d'événements
sur les les précipitations intenses
méditerranéennes par exemple donc il y a
des travaux je crois que la DGPR a
engagé des travaux pour améliorer la
connaissance sur les risques inondations
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui donc on
est quand même un petit peu gêné lorsque
l'on a des PPRI qui nous regardent que
la crue de référence qui s'est produite
donc au milieu du 20e siècle et qui est
le garantie ça nous fait de dire que les
crues futures elles sont forcément
couvertes par cette crue cette crue
passée donc moi je pense
qu'effectivement ça amène à avoir une
réflexion sur les crues futures et de
les mettre au même niveau que les crues
passées il faut les conserver bien sûr
mais il faut en rajouter des nouvelles
sachant que chers collègues il y a aussi
d'autres paramètres il y a le fait alors
sur la Vézère peut-être un peu moins sur
l'impermanisation des sols mais les
territoires ont également un beaucoup
étaient modifiés en l'espace de ces
dizaines d'années et donc la manière
dont le ruisselle et complètement
différente aujourd'hui de ce qu'elle
était hier et donc sur une même
pluviométrie on peut avoir des crues
plus intenses parce que le ruissellement
est beaucoup plus fort donc ça induit
aussi toutes les stratégies qu'il faut
essayer de mettre en place en complément
alors si en plus on a des des
pluviométries exceptionnelles ça
renforce encore dans certains
territoires qui sont assez
imperméabilisés le fait qu'on peut avoir
des événements vraiment majeurs et très
important et donc alors sa complexifie
bien sûr la connaissance des modèles
mais on peut pas passer à côté donc il
faut aujourd'hui améliorer aussi la
connaissance parce que demain aussi même
sur les la gestion de la ressource c'est
un élément clé
parce que par exemple aujourd'hui
on comprend bien que il faut travailler
vraiment sur la différenciation
territoriale pour essayer d'évaluer quel
est le projet le caractère d'impact des
projets parce que c'est très ça peut
être très différent en fonction de la
nature des territoires donc il n'y a pas
forcément une vision nationale des
choses ça ne souligne ça existe pas
partout et ça pourrait pas exister
partout de toute manière mais bon c'est
aussi une caractéristique du projet en
fonction de son territoire à un moment
donné qui a été imaginé ça veut pas dire
que sainte Soline est une bonne chose
mais en même temps sur les crues
colinaires et les bassins de rétention à
bon escient il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup
de questions qui se posent voilà
c'est-à-dire de dire mais quand on a
vraiment un trop d'eau et que ce trop
d'eau ne participe qu'à un ruissellement
un affaiblissement des sols est-ce que
le fait de pouvoir stopper ou freiner
l'eau à bonne escient n'est pas une
bonne stratégie si on la restitue
ensuite demain au profit de
l'environnement général et de tous les
usages voilà donc il y a des vraies
différenciations mais pour le coup ça
nécessite de la donner de la tous les
sens et le fait d'affiner par territoire
donc nous on était impliqués dans un
projet qui s'appelle flood qui avait
lieu dans l'Aude les inondations de
l'Aude je le cite et on était avec le
CNES on était avec la DDTM de l'Aude et
puis le CNES et c'était c'est un projet
donc qui visait donc à valoriser
l'imagerie spatiale pour améliorer la
résilience des territoires au phénomènes
d'inondation et donc de ruissellement
rural et voilà et donc c'était donc nous
on a porté l'information sur l'évolution
des plus extrêmes sur sur les régions
méditerranéennes mobiliser les acteurs
mobiliser les élus sur ces questions là
mais ils le sont énormément dans l'Aude
parce qu'ils ont vécu comme des
catastrophes à répétition ces dernières
années donc eux ils sont bien convaincus
de enfin ils ont bien vu la réalité du
changement climatique vivait sur le
territoire et puis donc avec l'imagerie
spatiale c'était de regarder des
éléments de détails du territoire mais
qui joue le rôle au moment de ces
événements intenses les les
qu'on a supprimé qui peuvent elle et qui
jouent un rôle de pouvoir ralentir
l'écoulement des eaux les pratiques
agricoles la façon dont on cultive les
les parcelles qui peuvent accentuer le
ruissellement quand on cultive le long
de la pente ou au contraire quand on
cultive voilà donc il y a tout un
ensemble de d'éléments de
de la réalité de la façon dont est
utilisé le territoire qui aujourd'hui
donc voilà donc qui était regardé avec
l'imagerie du CNES mais qui interrogé
sur des pratiques mais qui sont à
l'échelle de la parcelle parce que c'est
à cette échelle là que débute finalement
les phénomènes qui vont ensuite
s'amplifier et qui deviennent j'avais
presque dire un peu incontrôlable mais
voilà donc il y a aussi donc au-delà de
la LEA naturelle donc ça interroge sur
les pratiques qui ont pu être faites
donc qui ont évolué pour des raisons
donc généralement économiques mais donc
alors donc il y avait
l'imperméabilisation bien sûr mais il y
a d'autres pratiques qui peuvent avoir
eu lieu sur les territoires et qui
aujourd'hui aggravent ces phénomènes
indépendamment de l'aggravation de
l'alerte
et justement à ce sujet par exemple moi
j'ai un village avec des collines et
le la façon de cultiver a complètement
changé parce que autant avec les chevaux
on cultivait à l'horizontale là
maintenant avec les tracteurs on cultive
à la verticale et après les après les
fauches d'été le labour il y a des gros
orages on se retrouve avec de la boue 20
cm debout dans le centre du village donc
à partir de là
on a cartographié si vous voulez les
risques et on s'est aperçu d'abord on a
demandé aux cultivateur de travailler
autrement et de laisser des bandes en
herbé mais ça c'est chaque village qui
doit le faire et par contre on s'est
aperçu que en bas des collines il y
avait des il y avait des mares les mars
servaient à abreuver les vaches sauf que
il y a plus de vaches donc qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait on a
on les a supprimés et aujourd'hui quand
il y a un très très gros orage dans ce
disque Neymar elle servirait bien à
quelque chose parce que elle ferait
voilà et c'est vrai que on se doit je
pense dans chaque village de voir les
problématiques que l'on rencontre pour
pouvoir adapter son territoire et une
cartographie c'est drôlement important
je ne peux que vous rejoindre juste pour
dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a la
restitution du projet life artisan qui
était donc qui
regroupait les les solutions
d'adaptation fondées sur la nature
puisque c'est un petit peu ce que vous
évoquez de comment c'est ce que
j'entends voilà et de dire donc voilà
donc il y a beaucoup de travaux pour
quelque part peut-être
alors il s'agit de réfléchir donc
notamment là vous évoquez les zones
humides et l'intérêt des zones humides
alors peut-être avec aussi une réflexion
moderne c'est à dire que s'agit pas de
enfin à mon sens ça j'ai pas forcément
de reproduire ce qu'on faisait dans le
passé mais pas de le remettre au goût du
jour par rapport aux besoins que l'on a
aujourd'hui mais les solutions fondées
sur la nature donc pour l'adaptation
c'est même dans le rapport du GIEC en
sixième rapport du GIEC ce sont les
solutions qui sont les plus prometteuses
et dont on est sûr qu'elles ont pas
d'autres externalités parce que quand on
fait de
l'ingénierie souvent donc on résout un
problème et on a créé un autre voilà du
coup ça soulève aussi mais quand on
parlait des systèmes d'information et
d'accompagnement au niveau des process
et des filières c'est sûr qu'au niveau
de l'agriculture pour vous aujourd'hui
ça doit être aussi un enjeu assez
important parce que vous devez avoir des
demandes de plus en plus fortes quand
vous disiez la connaissance à la
parcelle et l'influence sur les sur les
assolements et puis les process de
culture
Météo France joue un rôle de plus en
plus important vous êtes sollicité dans
ce cas-là pas nécessairement
on avait développé un service un certain
moment
en collaboration avec
quel
valise avec et finalement ça pas ça pas
pris c'est ce qui a pas pris donc
c'était un peu une aide à l'irrigation
et puis également
aux choix des aux choix des cultures et
ainsi de suite en fonction des données
je ne sais pas pourquoi ça pas
finalement ça a pas débouché ça pas pris
et sinon dans d'autres domaines alors
c'est pas en tête moi d'autres d'autres
exemples actuellement
on parlait du d'un service particulier
mais j'avoue que je le connais pas
précisément
en fait donc le conseil donc aux
agriculteurs il est quand même sûrement
assez structuré on va dire donc ça passe
par les par des chambres et ça passe
aussi par des les organismes qui leur
vendent certains nombre de choses donc
aujourd'hui je suis pas forcément Météo
France c'est pas tout à fait dans ces
dans ces réseaux là donc
un peu de mal à percer dans ce
étonnamment
on répondra à votre question que je veux
dire
nous avons pas tous les éléments
forcément ici mais on rajoutera au
questionnaire on rajoutera un point sur
sur nous ce qu'on fait actuellement
quand on est gestionnaire à la croisée
des chemins justement sur les epcb quand
vous mettez en place une redevance de
bassin et que vous négociez avec la
profession c'est des
données aussi qui sont fondamentales et
des données d'accompagnement qui sont
fondamentales aujourd'hui on va passer à
côté et ça sera de plus en plus fort
c'est très clair plus en plus fort parce
qu'après il faut croiser aussi avec des
pays qui sont vraiment en stress qui
utilisent des processus l'eau sous serre
en Espagne et récupérer et réinjecter
dans des rigoles on récupère les vapeaux
de transpiration on récupère aussi long
réinjecte au niveau des serres enfin il
y a des process vous voyez il y a
énormément de choses qui qui
interviennent à un moment donné mais
du coup là sur l'agriculture enfin ça va
être essentiel d'affirmer et
d'accompagner en termes de connaissances
et pas que de connaissances donc les
évolutions des process
je pense que vous êtes directement
concernés
il y a plein de d'acteurs de
spécialistes dans le domaine et
peut-être que là aussi je sais pas si ça
pourrait être une recommandation mais
mais il y a peut-être pas suffisamment
de coordination pour fournir les bonnes
méthodes et le les aides qui vont bien
au
par exemple vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de Sainte-Souline et puis des
superbes finalement
des experts un peu isolés mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il y ait une
belle coordination pour pour
fournir des réponses
collégiales et puis
se projeter dans le futur donc voilà
c'est ce qu'on a posé bonne question
parce que même les études bergères le
bergère est en train de revenir sur ses
études initiales
il faut avoir vraiment une vision
globale des choses je crois c'est parce
que si on demande
Météo France pourrait apporter
éventuellement une contribution mais ça
à sa à son niveau
elle a pas toute la science sur le
domaine mais vraiment c'est cette
coordination qui qui pêche peut-être un
petit peu voilà il faut y réfléchir je
sais c'est une c'est une ouverture là
comme ça est-ce que est-ce qu'on partage
bien la connaissance de tous les acteurs
qui pourraient aider à avoir la
meilleure vision et les
meilleurs prospects meilleurs
perspective
consacre donc
merci beaucoup de nous avoir consacré du
temps et puis nous saurons
éventuellement vous recontacter si vous
avez besoin si nous avons besoin
d'informations plus importantes
avec plaisir donc nous pourront itérer
sur le sur les questions réponses donc
on fournira les éléments compléter
également avec la question dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure sur l'agriculture
et puis n'hésitez pas bien sûr si il y a
des choses qui sont pas claires pour
qu'on puisse puisque pour que votre
rapport puisse être le plus le plus
complet possible voilà c'est vraiment
avec plaisir et bien nous aussi voilà on
vous souhaite une excellente fin de
journée bon courage pour votre mission
merci